aujourd'hui pour notre calendrier de
Noël 100 % évelinois voici quatre jeux
issus de la société à modé basé à Guill
[Musique]
encour et tout d'abord le jeu
attrape-rêve idéal pour les enfants des
4 ans ce jeu les invite à une chasse au
cauchemar ludique un jeu de prise de
risque qui se développe dans un univers
honérique le monstre des couleurs vous
connaissiez le livre voici le jeu il est
coopératif des 4 ans c'est un jeu qui
stimule la mémoire et qui permet aux
enfants de découvrir leurs sentiments à
partir de 6 ans maintenant unlock kids
c'est une version adaptée du célèbre jeu
d'escape game au menu réflexion et
esprit d'équipe et pour les plus grands
me direz-vous et bien ne vous inquiétez
pas j'ai également une suggestion pour
eux Seven Wonders architect c'est un jeu
qui emmène les participants dans une
construction des SEP merveilles du monde
les règles sont simples mais la
stratégie exigeante ces jeux ne sont pas
uniquement des cadeaux pour Noël c'est
aussi une invitation à partager des
moments ensemble en famille ou entre
amis